afternoon oh I'm with my good friend
Chris learners chance explains we're
here for Game 11 the penultimate game of
the World Championship match 2012 hi
Chris yeah trifon hi we have the at the
yeah next to last game and yeah let's
see what happens is the last game in
which girl phone just got the white
pieces so in a way we can assume that
this is his last try to yeah maybe
decide the match before it gets into the
rapid playoffs mm-hmm so let's see if we
got game made some headway in this game
we have fun I think a pretty similar
opening to game nine right sonam so
again so you're 34 and then we went into
I names Oh engine so noisy free allowing
the Knights to be pinned so the king
yeah this also made me lost a small bet
because I I yesterday guess that we
would get a Catalan so ah alright it's
just just a little fun game that I play
with the friend of mine you guessing the
openings at least I what the first limbs
oh I got right but the second one I
thought that girl phone would maybe very
young earlier okay so we got him so
again and also the three variation the
reuben saw in Ruby Sonya you know and i
think the UM new move on compared to the
game before comes at move seven almost
eight so so the tension is is increased
again in the sensor like previous game
now we got castles which is identical 22
game 9 and now comes unknowns new setup
it's not a novelty but it's new for this
dis match and also doubt that you played
it before I didn't look at that but
considering that that girl fan spends
really lots of time and with nine I
think it was some kind of
quires hi ed takes you for your ship see
for now Bishop d7 yes this had a lot of
people questioning what the purpose of
this was because to a lot of people the
more natural move might have been maybe
a 64 b5 later if the bishop was gonna
come on this diagonal yeah I think it's
difficult to play for be five in those
setups because white would almost
invariably play a fort at the earliest
moment to prevent it I think the idea of
this movement one idea is of course to
put this bishop on c6 where it does yeah
basically quite the same things as it
doesn't b7 so you can easily compare
this to a set up with b6 and Bishop e7
but in a way on c6 it's a bit different
because this Bishop is anchored it's
very nicely protected all the time you
haven't we can turn away your queen side
in any way with b6 and also um perhaps
he acts the b6 square instead of a pool
number 6 black can also look forward to
our night d 7 2 p-6 later if the pool
yeah does this is one alley and also as
we see in the game leg will play Queen
a5 later so it's a it's similar to those
b6 setups but with a little twist and it
has some the practical advantage that it
yeah it is a surprise I think hmm um it
is a known move I think it has been
played before but suddenly knew you two
to girlfriend if you think I'm not
entirely new like I never saw it but it
looks like it didn't have anything ready
for this because I think you're almost
invested close to 30 minutes now to come
up with the next two moves yeah food it
was a chef or might be more and i think
i was watching so he played IE free
which a lot of people were expecting and
i think Peters viddler was going on
about time management in in the official
commentary stream saying you know if
there's not many alternatives to a free
perhaps it should have been played
quicker wise you have to count
a bishop a 5c takes d4 why think I think
and Bishop takes see free and your
workload is cut in in free if you just
wait for the opponent to play the one of
the free unless there's a viable
alternative to playing a free I wonder
white wasn't played are quicker here
yeah it's difficult and i'm not quite
sure about the subtle points here in
this position because what first of all
this she played Bishop b5 no I didn't
took on tinta guy on c3 and also not
only form yeah and this um it always
hard for me to understand because it's
not like I'm criticizing this move is
just the statement that I don't
understand it he takes later on c3
couple of books later yeah I'm not quite
sure what the value is to first retreat
the bishop and and then capture later
because white smooth some in the
meantime look pretty normal to me but ok
I'm not I'm really no expert and just
hard for me to tell this is the light
catcher in this French defense winner
isn't now would you can play Bishop 85
then lights but should take see free
that idea is in French win over is that
yeah there are also examples for this in
the news oh well black first place this
retreat and then captures later but I'm
not really I'm not in a position to
explain what's the point really I cannot
tell maybes faintly is 0 Bishop see so
no but it's not gonna be on the cards
it's not gonna be on the card the
intention is not to see him and the
thing is if white wood for some some
reason now would be forced to play some
Lucy he wouldn't play otherwise right
let's imagine blackmore take on c3b
texts rewrite wouldn't white maybe play
Queenie to rock do you want anyway I'm
not sure now Bishop c6 what do I have
plenty better move now then Queenie too
and maybe 95 stuff like
queening to is quite functional is
providing battery against beef if b5 was
useful for maybe see Four Queens yeah
seems to be a very sensible move for
that battery to prevent b5 some happy
would play Queenie to now and let's say
97 real q1 we have exactly the the game
position but Blake is the move up right
so he's actually losing a move yes
that's a major thing why would you want
to lose a move your right yeah it I
don't understand it it's not not
criticism it's just lack of
understanding hey I'm not sure maybe
when one of all ideas for some reason if
you wish you can play Bishop before I
hear what you did in the game let's say
goodnight Queenie to now which makes I
think lots of sense rock t1 is prepared
and now Bishop c6 young yeah now if
white would go on ID five which could
have been an idea after the immediate
capture then like I think would has the
option to simply take on default and
okay why do I could maybe play rock do
you want yeah okay so maybe this isn't
but now maybe remove like Queen system
maybe maybe this is the point in a way
to to still have those the center of
attention and it maybe this is a
nonsense variation possible just eat xt5
right and all black pieces are standing
on on on various various awful squares
yeah I'm not sure as you will be doing
that be4 might be useful yeah this is
just a bad setup like a slave neck is
just terrible here so I'm not sure of
the point really mystery okay yeah you
should be five well at least it made
girlfriend think quite here is actually
is too mysterious bishop moves one was
that and now this one so it's quite
funny isn't it yeah well chip should be
seven has a clear purpose it wants to go
and see 6 9 27 but Bishop f5 are not
quite sure okay queenie to UM bishop c6
and whoopty one and only now I took on
c3 yes oh yeah it's like
now yes okay my mini tempo is maybe not
not so porn yeah but it's just that I
don't understand it now I bd7 very
logical completing development yeah now
you can see that this header with bishop
on c6 and 97 that makes quite an ammonia
impression I think it's also a matter of
taste I kind of like the setup so i
would i would maybe consider this
playing this is black because i just
have a fondness for this Bishop position
on c6 it's so nicely protected there and
cannot easily be expelled from this
position if we try to grab a pool I
guess black plays queen I five yeah and
black is better I guess whose structures
right yeah and why the White has no no
idea really to get get something going
with this c1 Bishop you cannot play you
for this is I think the problem yeah
even even if you could play for it's not
not great but yeah this is certain just
just fine for black so Bishop d3
preventer prepare c4 or you fall yes
since that would liberate the bishop
either potential net diagonal or just
here it's a c4 or e for to try to help
this Bishop and I think Svidler said of
the bishop belongs on beta i really
liked his comments actually i was trying
to pick up some insights from the way he
was saying his comments he sort of knows
where pieces belong clearly in different
types of zishan 'he's i think after c4e
bishop does belong on that dial for d5
breaks for bishops potentially dangerous
the hanging porns could be protectable
with rooks maybe on c1 d1 so would you
reckon in that structure with c4 do you
reckon the bishop does belong on b2 it
doesn't belong anywhere else yeah it's
maybe the day a little way you want to
put it so it's a it's pretty similar
this kind of structure i'm not quite
sure if spindler mentioned this also
this is quite similar structure to a
queen sinyun with a 3 this patrician
variation
it's quite similar often there you have
a similar structure from White's point
of view but leg and this is the
difference here has got two nights and
doesn't have a dark squared bishop
anymore otherwise this is a very similar
structure and their white also plays
Bishop e2 and the kind of ideal thing
what you like to do is place e4 and e5
maybe as a pawn sacrifice young and then
trying to use those two great bishops on
b2 and d3 to attack you will find some
some very nice classic examples of
course barrels of course in this kind of
information yet this maybe you covered
this already in your your chest pay
series the game against portage was also
this kind of structure right shortish in
1983 I guess where he sacrificed on age
70 g7w ship sacrifice and this is kind
of the model game for the structure
whose last Kosovo's wasn't laska also
sacrificed bishop once like that yeah it
was exactly the same thing but there
were two gosh bishop sacrifices on on
age seven first and then one g7 and then
it got to this position where white got
an ID on f5 and you know when Gary's got
the nod on f5 it's always made yeah yeah
okay so let's let's get on with this
game so quickly I'm fine now why is it
this should be two possible I guess is
its I the queen is employing it might
come over here after Cindy so maybe the
bishop doesn't want to commit to be too
here maybe but one point officer could
be here um if you put it on the board it
should be to one point could be that
this bishop might be easily attacked
soon with the 96 yeah yeah yeah I fool
this could could be a bit ugly and this
also shows a point [ __ ] behind this
Bishop d7 move now SB six is not played
like an use this Queen a 596 to to his
advantage and this even might be good
for black already I'm not
90 94 looks very very inconvenient
unless a force working here also as a
tactic here is not c4 because takes you
can take care and double the porns
offense useful yeah well see for I can
play just Bishop c2 I suppose you know
that's that's keeping them Bishop her
request is what what happens if like
simply grabs the pawn on a form and I
think you can instead of what just
grabbed upon we deny it there's no point
in playing c4 really i think you know
why basa for let this just grab it
immediately a4 and then grab immediately
I've take four I don't think she formed
does so much positive of this point
Quinn sexy fool not now just from a
structural point if you I don't think
you want to close the center down no no
yeah now let's the song owns it just
looked for some know and I take their
for just four I'm so nice lately
forehand yeah I just grabbed it
immediately and and now you may be ready
to play just be 52 and drop the Queen
back it's not easy to see what white
should have here week 9 e five though to
try and get rid of that I don't know
that looks yeah this could be an Eddie I
don't like this pin take leave notes if
be fight well beef I was not possible
now and this pin looks nice they're not
sure this is yeah they finish ugly
you're right son might be disaster here
yeah maybe maybe yeah it's complicated
it's complicated but then maybe not be
684 hmm I you you're not really you
don't need to take you can also take
first and d4 is this any way better
you'll be eloquent to say maybe just no
image file this is the intention might
be um well in the game on um uh yeah I'm
sure black does not need to do this he
has got some alternatives but another
idea which is just very simple chance
especially for here yes get rid of the
best bishop yes you can also do this if
everything else fails and it's um I'm
not quite sure white could play a move
like Bishop c4 to avoid the trade but
this looks so a bit pointless I guess
hmm maybe not be six here I don't think
the thing is this Bishop is potentially
good on me too but unless white get c-45
and it's just a bad piece now yeah so
I'd like has very nice central control
very hyper modern kind of approach he's
got all these pieces nicely am using the
center I don't think it really amounts
to much so he went for see form and um
read the game yeah and no honor quickly
took on before he played all this very
quickly I was actually getting pretty
optimistic at this point for black
because you had such a huge time
advantage and I thought maybe if there
are some complications coming up you
know and it gets down to the crude
calculation and nerves kick in and so on
but what girl found played it very
solidly and very very professionally I
guess not mining to draw not trying some
suicidal stuff with it so yeah well
Queen h5 it makes a lot of sense
pressurizing the a3 Android yeah and um
we aren't here here he played Bishop f4
I think this makes also quite some sense
controlling you fire you could could
think about Bishop b2 but
I'm not sure if this is so helpful here
you might be your black can take you can
you can consider this because well bone
structure is not exactly beautiful after
this and when you move like nice volume
actually maybe yeah f4 is a good square
I'm not sure 19 @ h5 white might might
just returned to see one tog is a fool's
well I suppose is a target now a black
and play this but just as in the game
you could also argue for for maybe just
not taking immediately on CL f3 just
maybe to play an improving move first
like Roxy 80 yet something like this and
then if you compare this to the game
here why doesn't have 95 available all
rights and it's why we can play it but
it's just better thing yeah that'll be
um you could just take ya know you can
exchange the soffit just enjoy the
better point structure here 94 yeah
maybe even if all suspicious blocks in
my time pool c5 is good yeah this is
which this is the bishop and maybe this
makes it about equal still for white but
it's certainly not great maybe it's
equal so but it's only a question if is
equal for white it's not in question if
if white can can do anything it's just
we are fighting for their offer from a
structurally somewhat West position
which is the bishop isn't as dynamic
behind its own pool as it was in the
game strong bie controller the first
thing you would think of here is how can
i get this Bishop only three then a4 a5
trying to liquidate the queenside yeah
it's not not a great position so I think
we should be a force it's just sensible
it's what can you do this kind of games
here they're not especially
thrilling it mouth is just very sensible
chest with Nick and sugar for yes and
and now I think clever move Bishop f4
Bishop played a clever move not taking
immediately or anything just doing some
improving see for my mission like wenis
to probe later with might be six
potentially as well this these hanging
pores they can be fixed down or c4
delighted yeah the bonds are potential
issue so you've got Bishop f4 coming so
now Knight e5 unfortunately for the
crowds the Queen's are coming off again
but white wants to maintain a grip ah
I'll sorry we lost connection that so
sorry sorry okay we're back though now
we're back now aren't me that the
volumes okay so i was just say Knight e5
unfortunately for the crowd that the
Queen exchange is on the cards now the
Queen's are coming off the night you
fight but what could wipe do instead why
is a tricky position anything could you
do like what c1 and we've got this but
it's really a question if this is a good
move because maybe later oh yes yes yes
and its really used to move to try to
get something going on
side and it's I don't see you really
cannot really improve the minor pieces
and what would you play then okay some
matt bishop d6 bishop is that move was
that terrible don't think it's terrible
let's say rook e8 okay don't sure d8
might put some pressure on before at
some point hmm why no I'm not sure
what's better at first first class okay
now you've got you we should be 6a know
what it says target it's in it's just a
target for might be it's a target yeah
the thing it's hard to make any progress
yeah so all right 95 it's just it's just
some of that um fits the position vest
against hmm ok so um black exchanged and
took on e5 phone song yeah I know first
roof dat didn't move the light weirdly
first route yet and here i think we had
a position we are I think our network
more than one hole left and your humble
star to let's say 20 minutes or
something right I thought was little
juicy because her back and because well
after you should have it this is where
all these pieces are nicely protected if
I'm very contact set up here yeah same
to you decide so why its position
doesn't look so heavenly well
coordinated any of this the solo SI 39
43 m this kind of looked a bit tricky
you're done well here shoes glossy and
control this large yeah first trust move
a 4 think this is really important you
have to to prevent this Bishop four yes
maybe threaten a for nature to gain more
space mmm it's not silly moose are very
important and often the kinds of moves
that you missing again I'm to take you
on f6 some people on you might be asking
wondering doubling pauses is of no
benefit to
white hair he loses his bishop pair d
falls this week yeah this is a problem
the problem is double double pause I'm
not quite sure would be interesting if
you would have lots of time on your
hands to do a statistics how many donate
per gallon calls are really weak and my
guess would be that the majority of
cases they are not weak hmm just like
here because well I should why detect
their 64 yeah it's not it's just
potential pressure on this toggle maybe
the King can't come here the dog bones
and stuff like g5 did you take c6 it's
how to think how I should win if you
would give him back yeah because 38 386
and he said also giving up any hope to
have a clean rock Christopher's just me
yeah yeah so he needs these that Bishop
for the fence yeah as well as attack I
think I think another option mentioned
by a natalia pullini on chess games com
was actually F free I'm not sure bet to
keep the night out of the four is that
free pliable move at least the thing is
well what happens so if black weenie
goes through the truth is kind of Bishop
f4 thing yes like clear how much you do
publish this down but this is this the
point if this is so it's an issue and
now maybe 97 yes yes to be six that
would be a really quite annoying on c4
wouldnít an immediately threatening
night 85 Oh blimey night c5 hair Oh
blimey this could start to get very
unpleasant you're right
before I be 32 before take something
yeah I'm not sure everything with that
position me really fits in to do if you
got the time yeah if you might play
because it takes voice on my squares the
night before the bishop yeah you re just
I think it looks like you played it very
precisely hear this kind of missionary
for business and stops any forcing moves
from the opponent because that really
disrupts things these forcing moves
doesn't it so tonight the Nights invited
actually to come if it wants to be
aggressive it can do before f he's
played but what is it actually doing on
e4 okay it's wrestling Knight c3 which
is a dangerous frets Perry cuz otherwise
that's a bit of a disaster isn't it um
hi there yes I'm sorry so yeah night see
free husband Perry thinking of it I
think it's mostly irritating for for
white hmm and it's not that easy to
store okay you can play a 3 of it it's
got some since around six or so what I'd
be useful I think if every wouldn't bite
collapse Knight c3 immediately yeah you
just play you play f6 here and I'm d 4
drops yeah oh sorry sorry in this
position are we saying I fall 94 f three
years really really really really bad I
think ya say if we just follow at f3
9352 f6 Bishop g3 ruta 40 this is more
yeah this is also quite nice you know
yeah lovely yeah we have picking out the
right line that's nice yeah their
subjects the slightest
so okay but he played rock t3 just
covering all this and also attacking
potentially be seven yeah yeah only
issue with uncovered but this is just
temporarily yeah it's temporarily so
he's playing very precisely just stay in
the game and people were saying oh it's
George but he has to play very very
precisely to stay in this game is
hanging pawns are real problem is also
finding ways of attacking we're up d
free I thought that was a really good
move then brooke d free once exactly to
play hello f6 yeah yeah kicking this
issue it goes to f4 not to g phrase the
other legal movie goes to change the
night before and your Oh before I needed
ouch this is painful as well isn't it
rook d2 doesn't look good for why maybe
this is are not really good you can also
pay what 658 and you're the only one
thing for something here oh yeah cuz you
could cuz what are black has now
exploitable targets this is really solid
alright just fixing any fool yes then
the second key find the issues of a
folky hanging yes maybe this is the most
affected yeah something you will need to
be dead before more closely but it's
just it's just playing for yeah yeah
yeah so before keeping Bishop are no
Bishop EA nifty look look at looking
move as though maybe well as though
maybe Bishop g6 might be on the cards at
some point I believe keeping an eye on a
for putting pressure on c4 immediately
yeah the question is how'd you Kelsey
follow yeah now if you if you play rook
see one you lose the a porn I guess um
yeah you can just grab it um cuz there's
no rebound on that is there to a seven
um maybe just be five here see for Hayes
she finds one more thing alright this
rook takes e4 maybe maybe Roxy for my
aching let me rock III it's an idea
maybe b5 is even even more interesting
here because you don't want really a
skewer and yeah it's you know an
important also good yeah so you know he
played you really the move that bed are
the best here maybe so b3 protecting and
attacking at the same time and offering
d for an exchange of weaknesses almost
like rook takes d4 but it doesn't so
rook takes d4 was played hair you almost
need to do because if he doesn't take
now then what maybe place we should be
three and two starts playing horn yeah
yes inside like a 525 and trying to do
something against yeah these bishops
would look menacingly at the queenside
maybe like they sought maybe the bishop
can be left there but yeah b7 is an open
file semi-open fall for white that is an
exploitable target especially given the
bishops last move yeah it doesn't want
b7 and that vulnerable you took on your
phone and then should you free hmm we
need to turn over here I know it was
factory zone yes and maybe negative
reaction to behold yes the game
unfortunately yes as well more
excitement from this game off with but I
wondered I thought black was better here
or someone was mentioning say takes ok
draws agree but say takes what about 95
isn't that nice for black this position
hmm yeah I didn't I didn't look at this
yet I need to ah to think about this
Nazi phobia well certainly a move you
could consider does it threaten anything
I decide to rope yeah hey um what what
what what what could play mmm I'm not
quite sure i don't think that leg is
better really but hmm I mean even even
if i take on c5 it's not great it's not
the best move no doubt about it but she
may be a five hair looks looks
reasonable to fix that porn yeah i just
ate to be one how do you do you cover
yeah well you always take your knife or
moment anyway um after um yeah it's not
winning for this just it's just that i'm
trading all the solitude yeah yeah i can
also play with beef I for instance oh
yeah saw the booth rookie three it would
be to whatever what about this disease
difficult to make any anything others be
7s stillness and weakness so if brooke d
2 is are asking for trouble i suppose
just bishop every counter attacking the
night its strong here you know maybe
also only three you could consider
I think this this looks even tastier
than X is keeping the pressure on b7 um
okay rookie for his well yeah oh yeah II
66 here yeah 50 75 kg six yeah shooting
a c-54 suicide but I can just two more
square oh this oh we can't count we
can't attack this because simply i takes
and you're protecting the so it's not
actually a great deal black can do here
um I think you would like to to put the
bishop back on c6 after all so maybe
maybe move the rock on g7 somewhere not
sure well mm-hmm look too I don't really
want to yeah but if you nice the same
sushi fan Sheen that line actually on
this line actually there's Bishop c6
here all right yeah cool sorry bishop
c63 might be handy because if n like
what 52 56 I could think of f3 of course
yes and free to make sure you can you
can start calculating nit three also
yeah yeah this kind of stuff is taking a
for taking you to like ask why active
yeah interesting yeah
the thing is on goofballs cross I think
it's very lucky let it end in a row but
it's so I don't know you are you could
you could play on a couple of who's too
yes if you have this positioning in
supply which 100 points better than you
and this is it all yes he walked away
and it's all okay I just look like the
last person in the audience understood
wise yeah will be a [ __ ] oh dear this
is bad how it's been left unexplained
with we're here just speculating now we
don't really want to put an engine on
because that's not really a human
perspective I'm just it's perfectly
understandable that they don't want to
make a 60 Ruth game out of this because
it's very close to the finish now and
you think about yeah it's just one game
left now and after this you potentially
have those nerve wracking tiebreak mmm
so do you really want to play 60 move
the thing is one thing which really
indicates that there is nothing is that
V she offered the draw with I don't know
40 minutes more on the clock yet I don't
know 50 minutes ago [ __ ] 10 minutes it
was 10 minutes for 15 moves it's not
like super comfortable and he still
offered to draw I think if he would
think that he
you will have anything tangible as like
then he would have played on wii after
if you want more have won this game has
black the match would have been very
decided well i guess white can force
opposite color bishops here in this line
we briefly checks what about just Bishop
takes e4 if white wants to play for a
draw we should be free yeah and yeah and
then it's difficult isn't it you could
maybe play c5 opposite color bishops um
in this position if I can be taken that
you're done you can just take it
immediately Oh in this position I'm
sorry it was a dicho sorry I saw the
rope I'll so yeah I just play Bishop e3
and now c5 so you got the opposite color
bishops maybe this is dead draw if white
wants a draw this is dead yeah
especially as much we're getting almost
certainly a six-year 586 and otherwise
but I neck might be tempted to play on
if you will to ever compete locating
yeah you know it's wrong and maybe even
a fair result there yeah fine so we
quickly just to quickly do an overview
quick overview of this game so another
rubenstein an Enzo engine with a
surprising looking voters took quite a
lot of the audience Bishop d7 which did
have the effect of causing and Boris to
spend a long time indeed fault here to
come up with a 3 which Peters with the
thought could have been played quicker
to cut down his workload by met by an
order of three times if it just waits
for the opponent's move here then starts
calculating but now it's been a long
time on a three but um all of white
smooth seemed quite precise after in any
case so c4 instead of Bishop b2 and here
precise Bishop f4 clamping down on dark
squares so we had an exchange of Queens
where it seems to hanging pawns of white
would come
sated here by White's potential pressure
on b7 holding things in the balance here
this rooks swinging across to probe e7
and now swapping literally d44 b7
potentially but no also now after Bishop
e3 the option just taking on a seven and
here are always agreed okay so and it's
not the sort of game we go out of our
way to cover on our YouTube channels but
a solid high-class draw um okay so Chris
some anything else otherwise sure you
wrap it up them and wait for the final
game tomorrow yeah on Monday sorry
Monday yeah this is why I actually
wanted to mention it will be arrested so
i think it makes sense so that both
players get a rest day before the last
white game so tomorrow is off you can
enjoy the water and weather if you're in
Europe it's very very warm but I wanted
you to add something if you got the time
to watch the live broadcast on Monday
you would have on the only official site
I think I understood this correctly they
will have both so Peter Svidler and
bloody mac Romney commentating so it's
about the best you can get so it's very
interesting to listen to yeah and once
in a while they interrupt the comentary
for some very insightful documentaries
on Russian artists really excellent you
get nice video footage and also I can
assure you that those countries by
selecting will be very yes I found it
amazing to listen to his comments about
you know where things belong and time
management and a lot of practical issues
which you don't often get to read out in
books you know he was talking about
issues over to this and also we can see
the the last game will be decided to
figure out a playoff or we'll have a
decision ever last moment remember a few
years ago in Bulgaria everyone thought
you retired pay off and then crosswise
the final games oh yeah too much so yeah
okay yes okay i hope everyone on YouTube
enjoyed that comments on question or
questions on both our channels
kingscrusher and chess explain youtube
channels okay look forward to Monday
okay thanks everyone cheers